il est 21 heures sur la côte Est et le
moment de vérité est arrivé bienvenue à
la première soirée débat de la
campagne présidentielle 2016 en direct de Quicken
Loans Arena à Cleveland Ohio il achète
et vend des politiciens de tous bords
il est déjà impliqué hé il couvre déjà
son pari  sur les Clinton d'accord, donc
s'il ne se présente pas en tant que républicain, peut-être
qu'il soutient Clinton ou peut-être qu'il se présente en tant
qu'indépendant, d'accord, mais je dirais qu'il couvre
déjà ses paris parce qu'il a l'
habitude d'acheter des politiciens.
les femmes vous n'aimez pas les gros
porcs les chiens slobs et les animaux dégoûtants
votre compte Twitter uniquement Compte Twitter de Rosie
O'Donnell
merci pour l'enregistrement c'était bien
au-delà de Rosa oui je suis sûr que votre Twitter